this is Startalk and I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist I got with me today as my
comedic co-host Chuck nice Amy always
good to have you chuck it's always good
to be here
tweeting it Chuck nice comic and and you
get your bad boy sometimes out there I'd
like to kind of disrupt the world with
my tweets if I bring a truth to power
it's both depowered always good to have
you today is a topic I've long wanted to
have on this show really and it's just
it's an exploration of self-driving cars
Wow where are they where they've been
where they going okay all right let me
ask you before we even get into the show
because since you're fascinated by this
are you an advocate of self-driving car
I you know yes do you like to drive now
I've driven with you so I'm gonna say
that you you are a promise kids so I
don't long to get behind the wheel I
think you like it when you're behind the
wheel that's fine but I don't like you
know walk by the Car and Driver
magazines and have them call to me I
come back and look at the centerfold
the Ferrari centerfold yeah I'm not that
guy okay okay just cuz I'm God because
I'm urban right and when you're urban a
car's a liability right Vanessa and you
know what a centerfold really is for
what the perp in the Bronx you know what
a centerfold is supposed to look like
and it is not a car okay so so
interesting to me is that of course a
self-driving car would I think benefit
City people the most okay I think about
it right we're gonna park a car how much
does it cost to park a car you know one
of the great measures of the cost of
living in the city a couple years ago
was when the monthly rental would in
that rental what a parking cost yeah
yeah well your garage caused the rise
hopefully drive past the monthly
two-bedroom home rental in the United in
the United States yes the average across
the country yeah yeah so let's just set
that up so anyway so we're featuring my
interview with Larry burns mm-hmm my
burns used to be with GM and now he's
advising Google
he's thought about this a long time but
again I can't take this alone cuz this
is out of my this is out of my company
the house right wheelhouse so you guys
found for me this guy Alex Alex Davies
Alex welcome hey thanks for having me
excellent so your transportation editor
at Wired magazine that's correct that's
a thing who would have thought Wired
magazine thing yeah well I mean
transportation it's not only crucially
important to just about everybody
everybody moves one way or another fun
all these things are changing at such a
rapid pace that about a year in Africa
we decided that transportation needed
its own section so here we are well
that's cool and so you and so this is on
wired comm where you report this ok well
excellent so so the future has arrived
yeah I think I'm it's like it's or if
not it has arrived yet it's it's in the
vestibule if it hasn't arrived then
Google has the drumming Amazon has the
drone on its way and so and just a note
about Larry burns which is my featured
interview today I interviewed him maybe
a few months ago ok when he came to my
office and so that's what we're slicing
that in so he's a total advocate of this
new era alright and he wants to reinvent
everything the entire system top to
bottom ok pick up my interview there and
see where where we to where he takes us
alright when you think about the roadway
transportation industry the history of a
karl benz events the first patent gets
the first patent for a gasoline-powered
automobile in 1886 and i contend to film
bands of mercedes benz and i would
contend if someone dug up a 1900 vintage
car and then dug up a 2000 vintage car
and give a DNA analysis same DNA
mechanically royals oil energized
powered by a combustion engine
mechanically controlled actually in
gasoline and driven by a person and
operates pretty much independently and
you sit down with a steering wheel in
there yeah and so my boss at the time
Rick Wagner when I became head of GM
research and development 1998 he asked
me a rather interesting question he said
Larry if you were going to invent the
today rather than a hundred years ago
what would you do different and to me
that was not a question about anyone
technology it was a question about how
do you deliver the value that comes with
from the freedom of owning and operating
a car so this wasn't a question that
could be answered with oh I wouldn't do
I put a battery in it making an electric
drive it was really how do you preserve
all the freedom that people get from
being able to go where they want to when
they want to a car kirov all those side
effects which are 1.2 million fatalities
a year worldwide which is epidemic and
scale not a pedestrian ok Austrians
motorcyclists on any kind of roadway
fatality but then our dependence on oil
call climate change concerns so as I
thought about reinventing the automobile
that was really reinventing the entire
system and this new DNA that surfaced
was really electrically driven with
diverse sources of energy cars that are
connected communicating with each other
and along the roadway very importantly
cars that could drive themselves and the
ability to tailor design the car which
is the pathway to making it electric and
when you put all of those together
connected coordinated shared driverless
tailored you've got a different DNA you
get a different DNA and you get a
different experience for people
and today the I asked a lot of the
people and I when I make speeches do you
really like shopping for a car you
really like shopping to finance a card
you like insuring a car do you like
stopping to buy gas and pumping gas
you're like looking for a parking spot
and then walking from the parking lot do
you really like spending your time
driving the car getting that wash most
people say oh those are just things I
have to put up with to have the freedom
to go where I want to this new DNA gives
us a chance to deliver a totally new
experience it takes all those negatives
out of it and handle all these
side-effects that were concerned with so
Alex does your sense of the future of
self-driving cars match his sort of
global redefinition of what life with
the driverless car would be absolutely
and I think it's interesting to see that
it's not just people like Larry burns
who have left places like GM to tour
with the Google and uber types it's the
big automakers themselves are saying
that this technology is finally on the
cusp of happening and it's time to
really rethink how we move around but
they weren't the big automakers were not
first out of the box weren't they're
being reactive to these more innovative
more nimble companies in doing so yes
and I mean they would certainly say no
any time you talk to GM or Ford you're
like well this is pretty new to you and
they say whoa hey we're in the DARPA
Grand Challenges back in the early 2000s
where a lot of this work started but I
think you have to give a lot of credit
to Google in particular for putting a
fire under them and really advancing the
idea of a fully autonomous are all the
driverless cars on the roads today just
experimental yeah basically there are a
couple you know uber is doing it staying
in Pittsburgh and in Arizona where it's
actually picking up passengers but it's
still very much an experimental car it's
got engineers up front and they're
trying to figure out how well all this
is working and how to really make it
work back in 2010 GM unveiled like a
concept car which they called the env
yes autonomous electric smart car for
urban environments right and so let's
pick up my interview with with Larry
burns and see what he tells us about
that we team up with Segway and we
developed the vehicle called env env for
electrically networked vehicle and that
was the star of the Shanghai World Expo
so this is a two-person balance machine
and the developers of that at Segway
took their trends
transport widened it and put more power
in it and they went to Cracker Barrel
and bought a rocking gliding chair
monitored on there put a roll cage
around it in six weeks they had this
thing running and waiter and I are
driving it around in a warehouse in New
Hampshire in the middle of the winter it
was amazing you know how fast they put
it together so we showcase this whole
vision at the Shanghai World Expo and
when I see it what they call the smart
car on the road I think of that it's a
two-seater car to see to leave off all
the rest of they don't need or use and
so because it only weighed 750 pounds
you've got 1/4 the mass so that's wasted
material
oh by the way when a New Yorker see
the smart car they're not thinking oh my
fuel efficient they're saying wow you
can park that in well we thinking
parking what are you thinking anything
else and if the New Yorker shared it it
would never get parked because when that
New Yorker gets out of that car it goes
and picks up someone else it doesn't
gold Park yeah so what you want to do if
you're gonna have a vehicle moving
around you like that you'd have it
utilize 75% of the time not 5% of the
time which in all fairness is what New
York City taxis that's what they do that
that a principle it captures some of
this yeah this fact the problem with the
taxi though is they have six tenths of a
mile driven searching to pick up their
next person for every mile they drive
with a person in it if you have a shared
vehicle system and you use wireless
connectivity communications to connect
vehicles with with customers like uber
does you can take that six tenths of a
mile down to 0.05 miles 5/100 of a mile
so you did the calculation and we are
convinced that we have a mobility system
that's evolving based on driverless
shared vehicles that are tailored to two
people that can take the out-of-pocket
cost of traveling and owning an
automobile plus parking of 75 cents a
mile we can take that below 20 cents a
mile and give you your time back if you
make median income in the United States
which is 25 dollars an hour that's the
50th percentile income and you move at
25 miles an hour your time is worth a
dollar a mile so we're in a world of a
Down even calculated VAT yes is there
anything you don't know we're in a world
of a dollar seventy-five a mile for the
typical car owner dropping to twenty
five cents Americans travel three
trillion miles a year if you can save
just 10 trillion 10 cents that's half a
light-year 10 cents on three trillion
well you would know that yeah I got that
one I got
we surely malls as half a light-year ten
cents on three trillion miles a year a
couple dollar it's 300 billion dollars
yeah oh I just love that you will take
driving a car here on earth and find a
way to relate it to the cosmos so Alex I
think most people who are newbies in
this are thinking I will buy and own a
self-driving car they're not thinking
that the car gets shared so where would
you agree with this vision that this is
wait where it's going to how it's going
to come to us out of the box or is there
some adjustment panes do you think we'll
have to go absolutely I think when
you're talking about full autonomy the
car that's shared that you never drive
you know the Google pod car that doesn't
even have a steering wheel or pedals
that car is gonna be shared you get that
vision of shared autonomy which works
and part of that is a technical
limitation of these cars is people think
that within 3 4 years they can make a
fully self-driving car but not one that
can drive anywhere or handle any
conditions they think that you start by
making a cars capabilities like this but
that can only drive in this biggest
space that's why Google's testing in
certain cities that's why Ober is
testing in downtown Pittsburgh and
slowly expanding from there so the
shared thing in set geographic areas
really makes sense so so is this env
concept car is that still alive because
he's he's recalling that from back in
2010 I assume we've moved beyond that by
now is that correct I think we're beyond
that and when GM talks about
self-driving cars what they're using to
test that technology right now is the
new Chevy bolt the bolt TV that's the
first electric car that can do 200 miles
on a single range and it costs around
like 35,000 the vault or the Volt the
bolt with a B bolt yes
bolt like the dog like the dog yeah
that's why they change the name they
always say bowl TV right now because I
feel like maybe they made a mistake
aiming their car is almost the same
exact so now and you're right they made
a mistake because I'm still confused is
the vault still around the V volt is
that still around Volt is still around
they actually just put out a new version
of it last year it's really good
okay I just think it's great we have two
leading electric cars named after
physicists yes okay there's so there's
Alexandra Volta Alta after whom we named
this unit of electromagnetic age the
force right electromagnetic potential
the vault well and then you have of
course the Tesla right Nikola Tesla
that's just cool it's cool I just think
I would get physicist on cars this is
good it's very clear even electric
trucks called Nikola there's a little
truck company called Nikola egg-cellent
Wow again the first name and his last
name it will gives middle name is Mama's
name so let's rejoin my interview with
Larry burns we're gonna talk about the
economic implications and consequences
of this shift in our culture really and
who's gonna have a job and who's not
let's check it out it has the potential
to not only impact the automobile
industry but the energy industry the
insurance industry the retail industry
and how we consume food how we educate
ourselves and others and it's pretty
exciting is this all a rosy story no
there's a lot of jobs tied to these
industries that I've talked about and
it's the economic implications of
suddenly not needing drivers and
vehicles and a huge number of jobs are
tied to that so just like the future of
innovation always has been there's going
to be new solutions they're going to be
adopted the the world's gonna have to
change think of you we're in the horse
industry back before the car was
invented and you grew hay or you did
horseshoes or you had barns or you
cleaned up after horses and the
horseless carriage comes along and
displaces all of that industry that's
the the the proverbial buggy went as do
you make buggy whips anymore is it a
place in the catalog they asked to buy
no yeah but what impressed me what
impressed me 110 years ago was how
rapidly we transition from horses to to
horseless carriages because we used
horses for ten thousand two years yes if
there's anything that
shoulda could have had inertia to never
change it would be the horses yep 1886
Karl Benz gets the patent 1903 Horatio
Jackson drives across the United States
by the early nineteen hundred's Henry
Ford hit on the assembly line concept
and then by the 19-teens he's building a
car that his workers can afford to buy
so in there often running in 30 years an
entire industry basically goes obsolete
yes so going forward do you see this
autonomous car transition happening as
rapidly as was the transition to cars in
the first place absolutely I think it's
going to happen very fast I think the
biggest risk in coming companies in this
industry can make is to assume it's
gonna take longer than it's actually
going to take yeah so Alex it seems to
me that a change can happen not simply
because you have good PR people but
because it has significant economic
benefit to those who want to make the
change and then you make the change
overnight it's a it's a business
calculation but the people who would
lose their jobs right how does this are
you ready for that but in your column
how do you have you talked thought about
this how to transition this entire
community of people I heard yesterday
yesterday that nearly 10 percent of all
jobs right or drivers right people drive
trucks taxis means and most of them are
men right but train yeah most of them
are men and gone so what's what how do
you deal with this that's not really
clear yet but it is a lot of jobs that's
not my problem
Neal we here at Wired don't give a damn
about blue-collar workers is their
problem the way you began that sentence
I was certain there was gonna go there
there's something like 3 million
truckers in the United States and in one
sense it's a really good job because
it's one of the few jobs that can make
you good money without anything more
than a high school diploma and a
commercial driver's license and it is
going to be stressful on a large part of
the economy when those jobs start going
away
I think that'll happen gradually and if
you talk to people like Daimler and
Volvo the companies had also make trucks
and they're all working on autonomous
trucks because they see really great
economic benefits they're almost right
away but it's not really clear what's
gonna happen to those workers I think
you know like Larry said it's something
that's happened throughout time and it's
just growing pains yeah the difference
though is there you know like when you
sit buggy whips when you were in your
interview the thing is that buggy whips
found a home in the dominatrix industry
that will not happen with drivers you
have autonomous vehicles there is no
need for a driver anywhere so when we
come back we're gonna tackle issues like
traffic and accidents and fatalities and
other things that a self-driving car
might get involved in and and and who
who you gonna call when that happens on
Startalk when we return welcome back to
Startalk
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson Chuck nice and
right to my left if I Sarah you were in
an Einstein t-shirt today that I am you
feeling some Einstein is my spirit
animal is your spirit advisor ileus /
nice very animal
I made sir animals a beautiful thing
we're featuring my interview with Larry
burns who's a self-driving car
consultant fascinating where Google has
deep history in the automotive industry
he's thought of as an engineer so he's
got the engineer sense of the world
where they calculate everything and I
had to ask him he came by my office
several months ago and I had to it so
with slotting in the clips from that
interview so I had to ask her about
accidents and what could lead to
fatalities when nobody's behind the
wheel that's an expression right who's
behind the wheel right exactly and we
meant to we met at that one purpose on
purpose so let's check out what he says
how does that change the legal
ramifications of a highway death yeah
that's a hugely important question the
whole ethics be
this the legal system behind it is a
very important part of the story because
if I steal if I get on the road drunk
it's easy to point blame there legally
but if everyone is completely sober and
they get in an autonomous vehicle and
your software ends up killing them holy
[ __ ]
so there's that those are banner
headlines and without anyone saying but
look people twenty nine thousand people
didn't die this year no one is gonna be
no one pays attention to who doesn't die
yeah there's a fascinating analogy to
that and that's the history of vaccines
flu vaccines were being developed that's
a good thing because people die from the
flu and but the producers of those
vaccines were concerned that someone
could have an allergic reaction to my
vaccine and died and I'm going to be
held accountable for that people were
concerned about that flu vaccine because
if they took it they may have a reaction
and die but it's a good thing if I get
the flu shot not only do I not get the
flu I'm not going to give it to you
so that's a public good so the
government stepped in and crater was
called the National a vaccine injury
compensation program twenty five cents
of every flu shot goes into this fund
and the liability protection for the
manufacturer and for the person that
gets injured from the vaccine comes from
that fund so I think it's a good thing
if we go from 35,000 fatalities down to
a thousand fatalities I would hate to
think less yeah or even less I'd hate to
think that manufacturers won't go down
that road because they're concerned
about your scenario that the one time
the software doesn't work it causes
someone to die we're gonna have to work
through that as a society you know what
I think is gonna happen you know will
learn passed the thousand will
understand those fatalities well enough
so it'll go to nine hundred to five
hundred and they will get all the
fatalities out of the system got Alex
Davies on video Alex from wired.com
you're the transportation
guru what's your actual title actual
title would be editor but I so Alex is
there could you update us on so we all
know that there there have been
self-driving cars in in test modes out
there have there been any injuries or
fatalities so far the there's been one
fatality so far in the United States
that we know of and that was in a Tesla
self-driving car so it's not the full
autonomy that people like uber and
Google are chasing what Tesla has is
called autopilot where it's a car that
once you get on the highway or anyplace
with lane lines that doesn't have
intersections the car can stay in its
own lane and use radars to detect other
cars and stay a safe distance from them
and about a year and a half ago now in
Florida a man was driving in his Tesla
in autopilot mode when a truck was
turning across the highway and the Tesla
didn't slow down at all and slammed into
the truck and he it killed the occupant
and that caused something of a furor
because people are like this is the
first self-driving car death and there
have been fears that once that happens
you're gonna scare people away from the
technology that didn't really happen
ultimately and the USDOT investigators
looked into the accident Department of
Rehabilitation here yeah the Department
of Transportation said okay we're gonna
look at this they investigated the
accident they ultimately said that it
wasn't Tesla's fault
Tesla still went back and tried to
revamp it they said it wasn't Tesla's
fault if I recall correctly they said it
wasn't Tesla's fault because the car was
not the purpose of the program was not
to have the car drive you it was to aid
in you driving the car
therefore you are still considered the
driver of the car which means that
anything happens is ultimately your
responsibility so it's kind of a
technicality like that it's a little bit
of a technicality because even though in
other words the guy was misusing the car
because he was in the backseat taking a
nap or whatever
okay and he should have been driving
let's get to how did this fail
so it's Tesla never really revealed
exactly what happened but the that
version of the car used a combination of
cameras and radars and mostly it was
really dependent on cameras also to
detect obstacles in front of it that it
would need to brake for and what seemed
to happen here was it was a very gray
day and it was a white truck and the
theory is that the Tesla's camera had
trouble distinguishing that truck from
the cloudy sky and so it didn't stop so
then Tessa went back it revamp its
self-driving system it tweaked it to use
more cameras more radars and to
hopefully offer a better blend of sensor
technology just when I thought we had
discussed everything that matters with
self-driving cars yeah there's more oh
yes in my interview with Larry burns
check it out what happens to traffic in
the world of an autonomous vehicle yeah
traffic is a real important concern the
reason you have traffic congestion is
there's more people who want to use the
road than there is supply for the road
and because of that the traffic backs up
it's a fancy term it backs up
nonlinearly you're going and the
traffic's moving smoothly and all sudden
it's chaotic and you get a traffic jam
with autonomous vehicles communicating
with each other optimally spacing and
flowing together you're going to be able
to get much more throughput on those
roads when you get the crash out of the
system you're going to be able to get
more throughput every morning there's a
crash washer yeah next time you're
driving on an expressway watch the
people around you the car next fuel will
pass you and get in front little later
on you'll pass that car and get in front
of a little later on someone else will
pass both of you you've gone 20 miles
you get to that point all three cars are
at the same spot so all that Lane
changing isn't adding a lot of value big
over the road trucks can slow traffic
down we may be able to organize that
freight traffic in a single lane with
optimized spacing or headways between
the trucks to improve aerodynamics and
fuel economy reduce hours would
basically draft off the previous truck
and then the sparking in Manhattan
I've heard I'm not sure it's true
because I haven't validated this that
I've heard that 20% of the miles driven
by Manhattan cars in Manhattan are
people cruising around looking for a
place to park plus you've got the street
side parking and we may be able to even
organize our lives in such way that
those delivery trucks that block up a
street or on our way maybe they can
deliver at night and because that just
works with their overall business model
because it's autonomous perhaps so I
think there's a lot of ways to get a lot
more people moving on the roads that are
where they exist
Alex you have a ranking of which cities
in the country have the worst traffic
not offhand but the last I saw it was LA
San Francisco New York
Atlanta's terrible traffic terrible its
usual suspects yeah do you guys
calculate how much we lose in
productivity by being in traffic I think
about that all the time I'm saying the
way to get through a tollbooth
and there's you know it opens up to the
you know however many lanes right and
I'm looking at all these people and I'm
thinking we could be either with our
family with our kids worth the job it's
billions of dollars and this is a number
pulling off the the top of my head I
think the average Angelino spends like
she's dozens of hours stuck in traffic
every year and you think about the time
they could be spending at home or the
time they could be spending working and
if in a self-driving car even if you
can't get rid of the traffic right away
at least you could spend that time
working yeah doing whatever you want
well now I just felt no I'm against
self-driving cars altogether now because
I got to work now sitting here do my
work
that'll be expected I also might
collapse the audio book industry oh my
goodness that's a deal right about that
because that's when people make use of
that time to listen to their audiobooks
that's right right right and so do you
spend much time thinking about traffic
flow and rubbernecking and all these
other elements that that urban planners
have to think about because the
self-driving car would get rid of it
would eliminate rubberneck there's no
rubber the car doesn't give it
that's exactly you know as a matter of
fact you're mad at the car you're like
the card is a blue flashing lights right
and that's only because the car is not
black oh my god no what would be good if
the self-driving car had a rubber
necking mode where it got closer to the
accident so that you could see you can't
see would you like to see the accident
so Alex what's your take on the solution
to traffic do you see that as
fundamentally built into the solution
that involves driving self-driving cars
I think it is and because as you've
noted things like human error accidents
rubbernecking all that stuff that leads
to a lot of traffic but don't think that
once you put one or two self-driving
cars on the road the problems fixed it
could actually get worse in the short
term when you have self-driving cars
mixed in with humans because you're
still gonna have enough human error to
clog things up and you know you really
need a much higher percentage market
penetration to really start making the
difference on highways that stuff that
Larry was talking about I just read this
and it may have been in Wired magazine
as a matter of fact Alex that in the
beginning of self-driving cars being
introduced into onto the roadways that
the self-driving cars may be more
frustrating to those passengers because
they will defer to the regular drivers
because they'll look and say oh that
guy's an a-hole and I let that guy go
and so you'll be able to bully them
right so here's how that actually came
to pass we might have read the same
article okay you come to a four-way stop
sign yes okay now the rule is the car to
your right
is a the right-of-way provided everybody
stopped but suppose you come to the
4-way stop sign but you do a California
stop hey you slowed down but you didn't
actually stop right and you ended
self-driving cars is waiting for you to
stop right because it knows you moving
one centimeter per hour that it's still
moving it's got a way for that guy to
stop right so that we can then do the
4-way stop sign
right and then the self-driving car is
sitting there all day all day cause it's
getting bullied by this is a scenario
right Alex it's a real scenario this was
happening to Google engineers in the
early days they were just sitting there
at faraway stops and ultimately their
solution was to program their car to be
a little bit more human
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so there's another issue that came up in
my conversation with Larry let's find
out what that is check it out one of the
people who just like to drive yes you
know there are people who love to ride
horses
equestrian horse racing in the horse
industry hasn't gone away completely and
it's okay to ride horses and it's gonna
be okay for people who want to drive
that's great and no one's saying to you
you can't drive that's the last thing
I'd ever try to apply here that we're
going to impose on them something that
they can't drive a lot of these people
like to drive on a highway one in
California and a beautiful sunny day
where there's no traffic and curvy
mountain roads and that is a thrill the
thrill of the road but when there is
stuck in Los Angeles traffic or Detroit
traffic in New York City traffic that is
not enjoyable and presumably most people
drive as a utility element of their life
no so the model for entertainment most
of the miles are a utility everyone else
so so no one wants to take it away just
like no one took horses away yes so Alex
you I assume you agree with that that's
you can't just get rid of cars people
love their cars people who love their
cars love their cars people do I think
there's gonna be a nice little boom in
the in the racetrack business somewhere
where you can go where you can safely
drive as fast as you want once and I do
think driving will never be illegal but
I do see a world in which cities say hey
this is a self-driving
zone if you want to get in here in a car
that car has to be autonomous for safety
and for traffic reason or park the car
at the border and then you're gonna do
an uber eyes that a youth driving car
come on Jack Wow yeah that's I mean that
sounds like an awful place to live I'm
sorry so I love driving when we come
back we're gonna get into like drones
and shopping with autonomous delivery
systems oh my god that just sounded like
the most awesome shopping trip ever
where a drone goes with you to go
shopping and then it drops a bomb on the
mall you don't mean that kind of drug no
no not the military drone okay
when Startalk continues more on
self-driving cars and autonomous
vehicles we're back on Startalk
today's topic self-driving cars yeah
nation of Jetsons on the Brad
self-driving cars I just Chuck we've got
Alex on the line Alex from Wired
magazine with featuring my interview
with Larry burns who's an advisor to
Google yeah on on the autonomous
vehicles and he thinks deeply about
every dimension of this question in ways
I didn't even know people thought before
and it's great I was a great
conversation with him and so we got into
autonomous delivery vehicles yeah and
what how that would change a whole other
industry let's check it out it's about
goods movement as well you know Domino's
has created a robotic unit called drew
dollars of recent deliverables pizza
deliveries created Roo the Domino's
robotic unit 12 mile an hour vehicle
that can operate and deliver hot and
cold food to your home robotically
that's kind of neat but they think
that's better than maybe a FedEx truck
or a UPS truck or a postal truck that
weighs 4,000 pounds and a driver you
know I work out of my home office a lot
so I'll be sitting at home and doorbell
rings it's the FedEx guy
doorbell rings later it's UPS guy Postal
Service will come to the door what's
going on here why I have two daughters
my wife they're shopping online and all
this stuff is coming in the house two
and three times a day and you've got a
person bringing a one-pound item to the
door you know a 250 pound person
bringing a one-pound item to another 50
pound person bringing a one-pound item
to my door and our truck that probably
weighs for more than 4,000 pounds and
now we've got the people who develop
skypes of craters I think company called
starship technologies they've got a
little robot that can deliver two
grocery bags at four miles an hour so
I'm not clear exactly how all this is
gonna play out you know you've got
Amazon working on drones that can
deliver packages in 30 minutes by
irrational II don't like drones
excuse me like irrationally you don't
like drones you don't know yeah if I see
a drone I want to hit it with a baseball
bat for no reason it's just because of
looking at me why is it there I don't
care if it has a package for me it
creeps me out get out of my window you
know what fascinated me about is not
rational it's a non rational response
what fascinated me about the 60 minutes
episode on Amazon's drone wasn't the
drone it was that Amazon thinks it's
important to give me something in 30
minutes that intrigued me and I asked my
wife and daughters about that well
absolutely I can try those jeans on in
30 minutes and decide whether I like him
or not if I don't I gonna ship him back
mm-hmm so that's all about
drone can you hold on while I try on the
coffee can i watch you know Alex in your
column do you also deal with other
autonomous systems we do we look at
drones a lot and it's worth noting that
Domino is actually just joined up with
that starship technologies thing and now
in Hamburg Germany they've got little
wheeled robots delivering pizzas to
people yeah and and that really seemed
like a good idea because certain
neighborhoods you're gonna have kids
just really enjoying some free pizza
yeah my neighbor a to be adults
how could you have an autonomous
anything walking with a pizza in front
of you right it's not gonna that's that
that's a recipe for disaster
I don't know anybody who's gonna let a
free pizza just walk by you know drew
through coming and they will say that I
asked them a dike no no it's locked but
you know people still ATMs did last suet
and put on the back of the truck right
the ATM down the road so what you're
gonna have is a bunch of missing Drew's
on the pizza boxes have you seen drew
and you'll have like destroyed drones
that are going to Neil deGrasse Tyson's
house yeah Mr P shows for some reason we
keep losing drones that go to Neil
deGrasse Tyson's house and in the
backyard of Neil's house there's just a
pile of drones that with a base you
would need like to make drones that know
martial arts so so so I also wanted to
know also needed to know about flying
cars oh well isn't that the big promise
it is the big I feel grille right I'm in
the commute I'm and then I'm in the
science community and we all promised
people flying cars I still have to bring
it up with Larry check it out okay after
you give me the autonomous car we want
the flying car okay you are way overdue
for the flying car I just I just want to
publicly on record say you have failed
us on the flying car promise I failed on
the flying car promise as an engineer
why not okay and we're gonna have to
work it out I can't help but be
impressed by the progress on the drones
and how fast we've gone from not having
an aid to a lot of people working on
them you know I had the privilege when I
was at General Motors to travel a 25 20
to 25 countries a year for over a decade
I was able to see Mexican engineers
Korean engineers Israeli engineers
German engineers Chinese engineers
Brazilian engineers all motivated to do
exactly what
American engineers are doing and I would
wake up at night thinking about China
and realizing that the 25% of the
smartest people in China equal the
population of the United States that's
right that's a stunning fact and what's
happening with drones and autonomous
vehicles or those young engineers are
getting captivated by these
opportunities and when you put that much
brainpower and creativity and motivation
globally around things why not flying
cars Alex you wrote a story about uber
taking over the skies with flying what
was that tell me about this story uber
actually thinks that flying cars can
happen and this isn't the idea of a car
that drives sometimes and fly sometimes
it's more of a vertical takeoff and
landing electric vehicle so basically
you know it comes in picks you up
wherever you are flies up vertically
flies wherever it's going and then drops
you off and the helicopters like well
rich people already have helicopters and
I say well one you know we think that
this could be done electrically you can
do it in smaller packages and more
quietly than helicopters and so I found
some aviation engineers and kind of to
my surprise they're like yeah that's not
totally insane in a few years we'll
actually have the battery and the
Aeronautics technology to make these
things work somewhat efficiently but
there are a lot of other questions like
how on earth do you regulate them
how does FAA get involved how does
air-traffic control change so
technologically it's not crazy but
realistically there are some pretty big
hurdles and I brought up this point with
Elon Musk we met we interviewed him for
a star talk as well on all manner of
topics but in there I asked him about
flying cars because I he's like mr.
inventor right Rockets cars anybody
who's gonna bring us flying cars anybody
its Elon Musk Vaughn so I thought you
had a really good answer because once we
understand the point of having a flying
car yeah because you're stuck in traffic
and you and there's all this air above
you just travel through the free air
right and not then okay so what you're
doing is you're adding a dimension to
the traffic pattern
and when you do that you completely blow
open all the ways you can get from one
place to another you get this so what he
said was we already have a modern
version of that holding aside
helicopters you know what the modern
version of flying cars is tunnels okay I
think about underpasses right
Subway's all right oh here we are
no it's not flying but it is undefeated
under the traffic you are stuck in right
your railway cars go in mm-hmm and on
multiple levels even there yes right
problem is or not the problem the
benefit will be my flying car will not
smell like urine as long as you have
traffic lanes that are in a third
dimension be they tunnels bridges under
passes you know even here in New York
City there's the we have a Battery Park
underpass yes you'll have to drive
through Battery Park there's a whole
tunnel underneath that that's correct
that's basically a flying car through
what would otherwise be traffic and
still the best way to travel in New York
City I don't care what anybody says
is the subway even though it smells like
urine I would only kind of smells like
urine that's because I stopped doing so
so Alex have you have you thought about
Elon Musk's plan to build tunnels under
LA because this is again this is the the
flying car solution do you just have you
going another dimension have you have
you thought about that it's something
we've looked at and it's something we
actually talked to Elon Musk a little
bit about and our question was well if
you just build one tunnel that's not
really gonna solve anything and then he
came back and he said well yeah you're
thinking too small I'm thinking 30 40
layers of tunnels which is mostly insane
the idea of building like a 40 layer
deep tunnel structure under a metropolis
that's already full of stuff like
pipelines and subways and train tracks
is a crazier than I want to fly
not necessarily I want to go to the moon
we have been to the moon and you're
saying it's crazy thinking to put
tunnels under a city now explain
yourself
I'm saying it's crazy that Elon Musk
wants to build 40 layers of tunnels
under the city and I think it's a really
smart solution okay okay because for a
moment there I was like how did this guy
get a job at Wired now you want to build
it's crazy talking so youyou actually
agree that it's a good idea Alex you
just think that to the extent which he
wants to do it there may be a lot of
problems with that but to have a couple
layers of tunnels would be a good deal I
think part of my job is putting a little
bit of salt on Elon Musk's ambitions
let's get to my very last clip with
Larry burns and just see where he where
we land this plane okay check it out so
what's the future pilotless airplanes
engineer lists you know conductor lists
trains there's nothing the train
industry has to have two people on the
train one on the front one on the back
and right now that's a regulatory issue
not a technology issue it's an economic
issue for the railroad industry and
let's say suddenly you're launching
driverless over-the-road trucks and the
railroads are still having someone in
the front car so we're on the rear car
again
I think Society will find a way to work
through there's there's vested interests
and all of us
there's vested interest in the oil story
there's vested interest in the insurance
companies in the recession interests and
the auto companies the road building
industry and all of that but at the same
time we need to have a planet that
survives and the sustained
sustainability concerns and mobility are
about all these sources of waste that we
have and how we elect to move people on
goods around on roads and there's a new
DNA in town and there's a whole new set
of opportunities yeah so Alex that those
are quite summative marks there do you
have do you have a a sense of how you
want to sort of end our time with you I
think it's important to note that you
know Automation isn't quite here there's
a lot of work left to be done but it's
most certainly on the way all the big
players have bought in and I think one
of the watermarks there is that Ford
came out last year and it said we're not
an automaker anymore we're an automaker
and a mobility company oh so if you've
got for the biggest one of the biggest
automakers in the world saying this is
not only what we're doing we also have
to talk about mobility because
excellently not an oil company it's an
energy company that's how they think
about it okay go on yeah so I think I
think you are seeing a sea change that
all these players are getting into this
market and automation is going to touch
on so many things
even beyond transportation but within
the world of moving around trains
absolutely drones construction
agriculture mining driving trucking
flying I think you're gonna see it come
into every part of this economy but
since they're gonna be so many people
losing their jobs how could we make some
money off of this how do we get in on
this edge what I got more here but
there's a little bit of that interview
that didn't make it to these chosen
clips oh yeah and that was what's the
limit of the uber model and not to
interrupt me if you want to hear that
full interview you can do it on Startalk
all-access comm
the full interview with Larry Berg full
interview yes yeah so the limit of the
uber model is you don't even own a screw
driver you just call up a screw driver
and a screw character gets delivered to
your window sill ten minutes later Wow
there's a shared screwdriver and if you
need a hammer why keep a hammer why keep
why keep a you know waiting for the
tools the the power toolbox of our power
tools well I keep anything that you use
once a month right exactly have that
stuff fly so what that would mean is
there will always be these hammers and
screwdrivers and and power tools just
floating around looking for who would it
deliver to you use it and then you give
it back you don't even need a garage
under those conditions I already do that
I have a neighbor
Chuck can I get my lawnmower back so
Alex thanks for joining us on Startalk
happy you've got you got a column and
wired.com and mom / transportation the
transportation we got you and that's
where we can find you Chuck always good
to have you as my co-host and and you've
been listening and possibly watching
Startalk on this episode involving
driverless cars and automated delivery
systems I've been your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and as always I sign off
by bidding you to keep looking up
[Music]